las dos ceremonias que tuvieron lugar
aquí en el castillo de Windsor quizás
han sido las más simbólicas y también
íntimas de todas las que han tenido
lugar estos últimos 11 días en que el
Reino Unido ha dicho adiós a la más
longeva de sus Monarcas primero
simbólica en la entrada al castillo con
ese gran Paseo del coche fúnebre estatal
en que iba el féretro de la Reina Isabel
a través de este long Wok este largo
paseo que lleva hacia el castillo casi
50 minutos el féretro cubierto con el
estandarte real y encima esos
instrumentos del Estado la corona el
cetro y el orbe que finalmente serían
retirados en la ceremonia religiosa pero
sobre todo simbólica porque la familia
real no iba acompañando este carro
quienes iban allí eran quienes
trabajaron durante años con la monarca
sobre todo aquí en el castillo de
Windsor adelante del auto sus dos pajes
y detrás muchos de sus mayordomos porque
justamente revolucionarios de la casa
real eran hoy los principales invitados
a este servicio religioso y
posteriormente al entrar al castillo
tampoco era la familia real quien la
esperaba sino que sus dos perros gorkies
y también su caballo Emma su caballo
favorito recordemos que la equitación
era una de las grandes pasiones de la
monarca a las que se dedicaba
especialmente en este Castillo luego sí
la familia real se unió a ella al
interior y realizaron esa procesión de
casi 20 minutos hasta la capilla de San
Jorge donde Obviamente el momento más
simbólico fue cuando el Joyero de la
corona retiró nuevamente esos
instrumentos del Estado la corona el
orbe y el cetro para dejarlos en el
altar y Carlos III el rey el hijo de
Isabel segunda puso finalmente ese
estandarte de la guardia de los
granaderos sobre el féretro recordemos
que la segunda parte de la ceremonia fue
completamente privada el cerebro fue
descendido a la bóveda real casi dos
horas más tarde la familia real vio o
presenció la entrada del féretro de la
reina la capilla que había construido en
1960 para albergar sus restos pero
también los de su padre de su madre su
hermana la princesa Margarita y ahora
también los de su esposo el príncipe
Felipe que falleció en abril del año
pasado y que entró hoy con ella a esta
morada eterna